vamos a resolver algunos problemas de
geometría espacial déjame empezar con
este dice se muestra un prisma
triangular aquí está el prisma
triangular hay varias figuras en
geometría espacial que tienen que ver
con triángulos por ejemplo está la
pirámide con base cuadrada que es un
cuadrado del cual salen cuatro
triángulos o bien está la pirámide con
base triangular
hay varias ahorita no quiero confundirte
solo quiero decirte que hay varias
figuras que involucran triángulos la que
ahorita nos interesa es esta de acá que
simplemente es un prisma triangular vale
déjame seguir leyendo el problema bueno
primero borro ahí está dice si la base
del triángulo es b igual a 7 o sea está
y 7 la altura del triángulo es h igual a
3 está es 3 de hecho voy a ir marcando
esta información porque suena importante
entonces la base de 7
la base es igual a 7
la altura es h 3
h 3 aquí el ángulo recto y la longitud
del prisma es el igual a 4 y estoy acá
sl igual a 4 n igual a 4
cuál es el volumen del prisma ok
entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es
determinar el área de este triángulo y
luego para dar profundidad multiplicamos
esa área por l 4 y eso nos daría el
volumen entonces déjame empezar
calculando el área de este triángulo de
acá vale déjame ponerlo entonces por
aquí que el volumen que nos interesa es
igual al área de este triángulo que es
igual a un medio de su base por su
altura es un medio de su base que 7 por
su altura que es 3 por su altura que es
3 x esta longitud que es lo que le da
profundidad entonces es multiplicado por
4 muy bien vamos a ver cuánto nos da un
medio por 4 es 2 2 por 7 es 14 y 14 por
3 es igual a 42 entonces el volumen de
este prisma triangular es igual a 42 y
aquí tendríamos que poner unidades pues
cúbicas verdad pero no nos dan unidades
si fueran centímetros tendríamos que
poner centímetros cúbicos pero al
parecer ahorita no nos importa vale
bueno déjame pasar a otro problema
el problema dice lo siguiente se muestra
un cubo si cada lado es igual a x igual
a 3 cuál es el volumen total del cubo ok
entonces tenemos que x es igual a 3 es
la longitud de cada uno de los lados
este de aquí mide 3 este de acá mide 3
este de acá también mide 3 vaya a todos
los lados miden 3 este de aquí también
mide 3 entonces lo que tenemos que hacer
es algo muy similar a lo del ejercicio
anterior debemos determinar el área de
esta cara el área de esta cara y luego
para poner longitud o para meterle la
profundidad y hacerlo 3d y obtener el
volumen tenemos que multiplicar por este
3 que nos da la profundidad vale bueno
entonces lo voy a poner por aquí tenemos
que el volumen el volumen del cubo es
igual a esta área que es 3 por 3 3 por 3
multiplicada por este 3 que nos da la
profundidad por 33 por 3 699 por 33 27 y
de esta forma el volumen del cubo es
igual
siete unidades ubicadas otra forma de
pensarlo es hacer tres por tres por tres
con leyes de los exponentes nos queda
que es igual a tres a la tercera
potencia y de hecho por esta razón
elevar a la tercera potencia se conoce
como elevar al cubo porque justo
consiste en tomar un cubo con él con el
lado correspondiente y multiplicar es el
número tres veces consigo mismo 1 por la
base 1 por la altura y otro por la
longitud y profundidad depende de como
quieras llamarle bueno entonces aquí
tenemos que el volumen de este cubo es
27 unidades cúbicas